veamos si podemos encontrar cuantos del
límite de x entre el logaritmo natural
de x cuando x tiende a 1 y como siempre
pausa el vídeo e intenta encontrar la
respuesta bien nosotros sabemos por
nuestras propiedades de los límites que
esto va a ser igual al límite cuando x
tiende a 1 de x entre el límite cuando
existente a uno de el logaritmo natural
de x ahora el valor de este límite que
tengo en magenta es muy sencillo ya que
la gráfica de la función ya iguala x es
continua para cualquier número real y
por lo tanto va a ser continua cuando
nos tomemos el límite cuando x tiende a
1 así que el resultado simplemente será
la función evaluada en 1 lo cual es
simplemente 1
así que ya tenemos el numerador bien y
el denominador bueno el logaritmo
natural no está definido para todos los
números reales por lo tanto no es una
función continua en todos lados pero si
es continua en x igual a 1 así que si es
continua en x igual a 1 el límite va a
ser simplemente la función evaluada en 1
entonces esto será simplemente el
logaritmo natural de 1 el cual claro
sabemos que es 0 recuerda esto elevado a
0 es igual a 1 entonces esto va a ser
igual a 1
entre 0 y los de poniendo con sus
respectivos colores pero en este momento
estoy seguro que debes de estar atónito
ya que uno entre 0 no está definido si
tuviéramos algo como 0 entre 0 no
necesariamente tendremos una forma
indeterminada y esto lo veremos en
futuros vídeos de hecho en algunos de
ellos vamos a construir herramientas
para trabajar ese tipo de límites es
decir el caso donde tenemos cero entre
cero pero en el caso donde tenemos uno
entre cero o una constante entre cero
esto es simplemente indefinido lo que
nos dice que este límite que buscamos
simplemente no existe
déjame escribirlo no existe y ya con
esto hemos acabado